when he thank you so much for joining us
on dividing thanks for having me on tell
us about the book and how it came to be
sure so it's um it's a fictional
retelling a factual reimagining of
basically my own rape right so ten years
ago actually eleven at this point I was
walking through park on a Saturday
afternoon in Belfast and I was assaulted
what was followed by a teenage boy who
then followed me to a more remote part
of the park and I was violently
assaulted and raped and that one event
you know change of course my life as it
does for many victims of sexual assaults
and I just remember thinking shortly
after that you know that incident you
know my life had been completely changed
I remember thinking well you know what
had happened to that boy in his life
that had led him to being a violent
rapist at the age of 15 so I it kind of
prompted me to like really think about
where we go in our law in our life
trajectories and how we end up growing
into the people we are how we end up
making the decisions that we make so
many people will be movie just be
gobsmacked that you know we're almost
fascinated to the extent that you would
explore in in fiction who your attacker
was a lot of rape victims do think about
the rapist and obviously we don't want
to write obviously there's a huge amount
of trauma that comes just even with the
thought of somebody who appears like
their rapist right I remember in the
days right after my rape if I just
passed someone that had a passing
resemblance to him I would be you know
thrown back into trauma and I'd get
panic attacks so in some ways you can't
escape the idea of that person right and
that's something I think a lot of people
that haven't been through that kind of
trauma don't really realize you're
constantly haunted by the specter of
that person who raped you right so yeah
so that was pretty much me for years
right and I had post-traumatic stress
disorder anxiety depression you know my
life was completely upended and
disrupted and it took me five and a half
years to rebuild it and then I kind of
realized well okay I mean I'm not just a
rape survivor right I have whole life
before then and I was always a writer so
I realized I wanted to be as a writer I
wanted to try to imagine that person's
life and in imagining that person's life
did that allow me to gain some kind of
control at least maybe only artistic
control over telling that story
allowed me to I guess transform this
awful thing that happened to me into
something maybe more meaningful I
suppose more positive because at the end
of the day I wrote the book because I
wanted to do justice to the survivors
experience and try to show that you know
survivors victims
aren't just you know weak victims whose
lives are ruined you know we have agency
we can make our own decisions we can
tell our own stories but I also want to
show that you know there is there is
this need to look at the rapist and
there is this need to consider them as
human beings and realize that they're
not just born monster as people aren't
born rapist they somehow evolve and
develop that kind of behavior what
insight have you through through dark
chapter and through the more academic
work what insight have you had into you
know the mindset the rationales provided
by your own attacker yeah I don't know
right and I'm never gonna know that
particular person and in some ways like
I'm not a rapist so I'm never gonna know
why somebody rapes but I suppose there's
different ways of imagining there's on
some level there's a sense of
entitlement to women's bodies right and
in the case of my rapist he was 15 years
old he wasn't from a very privileged
background at all who's from from an
Irish Traveller background so it's quite
a lot of racism and stereotyping against
his on his community so the way I try to
imagine him was the sense of a person
who was living on the margins never felt
like he got anything so by overpowering
somebody you know I was I was beaten
quite badly I thirty-nine separate
injuries after the assaults by by
overpowering somebody through physical
force and sort of getting what you want
sexually is that a way to feel powerful
in some moment and I feel like maybe
that's kind of a theme that runs
throughout the stories of many of these
perpetrators whether that's somebody
incredibly privileged or somebody who
isn't privileged it's about using rape
and sexual violence to I s'pose achieve
a sense of power at least for a moment
over someone I mean what are we what do
we then get getting wrong moving back to
the euro folks I mean what are we
getting wrong when it comes to sexual
violence but you said that we need to
challenge a kind of a public ignorance
your own sexual violence oh wait are we
ignorant well right but I mean I suppose
that's changing a little bit with the
past few years with the hashtag me too
and times up and you know you're hearing
many more voices of victims and
survivors out there on me in the public
dialog but I think automatically there's
a sense of shame right around rape or
sexual assault right so after my rape it
was very heavily reported in the media
at the time so I was it was in Northern
Ireland and a local media I think the
same day as my assault we're going on
about you know
Chinese woman violently raped in a park
and beaten by a teenage boy right um so
it had these sensationalist elements
right because okay I guess I'm not from
there so it was exotic Chinese and then
he was 15 years old I mean or he was
described as being a teacher shame I
would imagine on the part of the people
of the of the time that this incident
happened yeah and I think that's what
prompted a lot of the outcry like oh
it's awful it's it's it's almost
shameful for Belfast that this has
happened to a tourist you know but but
then there was also all this outcry
about you know it's Belfast still a safe
city so two days after my assault I
remember I was just googling my rape
right as you - but I'm a curious person
so I googled rape west Belfast
um and I saw all these different news
stories about my rape and it was
incredibly weird then probably surreal
right to be the person who's been
described as the victim in these news
stories and to have all these different
strangers talking about something
incredibly private and incredibly you
know personal that's happened to you and
using it sort of as a talking point
about his Belfast a safe city so there
was this radio show the Stephen Nolan
show which I I listened to and um and
they had this call in there was like
half an hour
strangers calling in about talk about my
free price so it's really weird to hear
all these strangers talking about it's
not knowing who I was right and
obviously my identity was hidden at the
time and the woman called in and she
said well my heart goes out to that that
we Chinese girl not gonna try to do
Belfast action but she said my heart
goes out to that we Chinese girl because
her life is now ruined and I remember
hearing that and this was two days after
my own rape and things like that's
really weird because this complete
stranger has just pronounced that my
life is ruined so that's one form of
ignorance I suppose and obviously I know
that came from a place of sympathy but
if the sense that a woman's been raped
in there for her life is ruined it's
destroyed is really damaging it's
temporarily destroyed I'll tell you that
much but it you know it is possible to
recover and I think we really need to be
emphasizing the path towards recovering
the possibility of recovery and not just
kind of assuming this woman's been raped
let's kind of throw a blanket over her
and let her live in shame for the rest
of her life
like that person can reclaim their life
and that person can go on to do other
things and make an impact and even
though the rape does temporarily destroy
you and it did for me for years like you
know it's not like that's gonna be the
end of your life so that's one thing I
suppose we are just on that topic on
one hand so much progress has been made
within the criminal justice system to
dealing with victims nowhere near where
we need to be of course but compared to
where we were 30 years ago and at the
same to and at the same time as there's
this quite amorphous amorphous phrase
rape culture that seems to keep being
mentioned what do you understand that to
mean I mean I would say rape culture as
a culture that encourages the
objectification of women as sexual
objects and condoned and maybe even
encourages sexual assault and harassment
towards them right so a lot of people
you know you can find this in like media
classes or you know kind of feminist
you know seminars where people you flip
through a magazine you look at all the
ads where women are sexualized right and
women become sexual objects and so some
people say local that's an example of
rape culture and yes it is but obviously
those ads aren't responsible for women
being raped yeah so it's a kind of a
number of things happening within the
culture that enable that so yeah you
could say the over-sexualization of
women in ads and you know in the media
well how do you feel that but about the
women who are exploiting their own
sexuality their own beauty or whatever
in the way that the advertising agencies
of the 30s 40s and 50s we did I think
about the Kardashians yeah life on
Instagram for example yeah but I mean
but I do you think yeah obviously it's
it's it is what they were and I think a
lot of men often say look women they
they probably benefit so much from like
from their own sexuality and I mean
maybe I support like you know I can go
on forever about this right but like for
example if you look in films there's
often this image of the femme fatale
like the sexy woman who uses like her
sex and her attractiveness to like lure
men to their death and like I actually
don't know a single woman like right you
know so I don't know if that's just
serving an invention could only a male
and benshan of a certain kind of woman
but I suppose there is this notion of
you know women are often seen as we're
often sexualized by you know the male
gaze by male directors by male author is
that kind of thing so there's a sense
that we have a power because because of
how we look but at the end of the day
you know one-fifth of women have
experienced some form of sexual assault
right and experiencing sexual assault
goes on to have a whole series of
lived negative impacts on you for the
rest of your life so I don't really
think you can say that like we have all
this power when a fifth of us are going
through these kinds of experiences do
you think that that buried somewhere in
sight all men could be capable of so of
some degree of sexual violence Wow
I don't know and that I like I am NOT a
man so I don't understand the male sex
drive and that's one reason I tried to I
suppose explore that by writing the book
but they're having some interesting
surveys so there was survey done in the
United States several several surveys
done of university men right and the
question was okay you're the party
you're with a girl you're horny she's
passed out drunk would if she's passed
out drunk and you knew you could have
sex with her and get away with it would
you still do that and 25% of the men
surveyed said yes right so they didn't
use a word rape in that survey but I
mean if a woman's passed out drunk she
can't give her consent and so that this
is actually the definition of rape but I
think those men probably who said yes
wouldn't think of themselves as rapists
so I you know I don't that's not an
answer to your question but it is this
notion of yeah I don't know and I don't
think most men are campbell of rape but
i've see there's some there are some out
there and they create call this huge
amount of damage how do we shift the
conversation to the place where you want
it to be where the shame isn't there
whether that where women aren't huge
first as or even second or third but not
beautiful as a sexual object possessed
or you've a few things well so the shame
like why is the shame there in the first
place I don't know I mean I I don't
think I should have to be ashamed of
something which another person did
wasn't your fault
right yeah the very definition of sexual
assault was it didn't involve your
consent so so that's one thing to
understand is you know we shouldn't be
ashamed of having been rape the person
that should feel the shame should be the
perpetrator right and then another thing
is obviously just centering survivors
and putting us in the center of the
conversations and maybe sometimes it's
we're a bit scared to talk about it I
think with enough encouragement the more
we hear about these stories the more we
start to realize that actually only one
in ten rape victims is raped by a
stranger you know nine out of ten rape
victims were raped by somebody they
knows that's a friend or their own
husband or a colleague you know or
somebody in their family so whose
experiences are important to listen to
and realize
can we go about kind of changing you
know the public policy in a criminal
justice system and you know the way we
educate people about sexual consent so
that people aren't committing these
crimes in the first place listening a
bit more seems to be a good place
absolutely Emily thank you so much for
joining us appreciate it thanks Neil
thanks